method number two instead of slipping
assets its X and y-intercept
pearl okay so here's the way it works
okay you still get an equation you still
got a set of axes but the steps will go
to go through a slightly different
slightly different okay we want to use
like two points and join them up that's
that's kind of what we're doing every
single time you got two points you can
just draw a line between them and
there's your graph that's great okay so
the x and y-intercepts are two
particular points that are usually very
easy to find now you already know the
y-intercept is right we've just
practiced how to read the right
y-intercept off of this graph right
where's the y-intercept which number
it's the ball
it's the +4 isn't it then go okay so I
can say the y-intercept is equal to four
okay sir I'm gonna put this onto my
graph I'm gonna go one two three there's
my y-intercept okay now last time at
this point like this is all the same so
far at this point what we did was we
went to the gradient okay and we've drew
a triangle thing in here and then no
worries okay this time we're gonna do it
slightly differently see how this is the
y-intercept
right well there's a y-intercept logical
to say this should be an x-intercept
also right it should hit this axis as
well okay now here's the way we're going
to do it right so maybe you want to put
this working on the side to find the
y-intercept is just sitting there to
find the x-intercept okay
make y equal zero now you're like huh
what's that mean I'll show you to say it
stay with me show you I mean you take
this y equals -2 X plus 4 right and I'm
gonna make y equal to 0 just for a
second to see what happens okay so
instead of Y I'll write down 0 right no
why then I go like this ok so I've
written down this right now oh I'm
these kinds of things before this is an
equation I can solve this
I wanna get X by itself any suggestions
for what I can do I can I can divide
what should i / hold on I can do by I
can add give me suggestion one
suggestion those hippie oh you say what
was your you gonna okay now you've got
to be super careful okay we are gonna
add and subtract some things but we
can't just add chill tell you why okay
this - too late it's minus 2 times X
it's not minus 2 plus yeah I should
actually divide right so I'm gonna
divide like it / - yes let's do that
what 0 / 2 0 2 divided my chance give me
minus 1 that's an X what's 4 divided by
2 it's 2
okay now this is good by the way I don't
really have to write minus 1 times X I'm
just write minus X okay um but I don't
know it so what can I do now I want know
what x equals something I should add X
to both sides just to 4 - that's also ok
so here's nothing to do if I add X to
this side it will just become X if I add
X to this side it'll cancel out this
negative right so I'll just okay now
here's the important thing okay um see
how we made Y go zero and then we got x
equals 2 these guys together right the
helmets exactly in fact they're not just
mates they're what we call quantity we
looked at cornets before we started with
coordinates it means that yes right Shh
x equals 2 y equals 0 they match up
together like this to 0 this is the
course away I write the coordinates
there's the X and there's the Y okay so
where is that on this graph well to
write the positive direction
I'll go 1
- that's where it is - y-intercept for x
intercept - I've got my two points so
now I do X Y let's do it I missed
actually I've seen people do it I see
people like draw extra-wide study their
wine it's like look see I got it
okay so they go that is y equals -2 X
plus 4 now by the way but when we went
about it was we worked out two
intercepts we didn't talk about gradient
at all but you can kind of see the great
inseam there's and then look say the
great it's negative what does that mean
what didn't what does the significance
of that look it's going down see it's
dropping down the gradient is negative
and secondly the gradient is negative 2
& 2 is quite steep that's why it's
dropping quite fast you see that
ok so let's summarize shall we these are
again we'll write up the steps
ok ok step one is exactly the same okay
you prepared so what was preparing you
write down the equation and you draw the
axes good always stop there okay
now the second thing we did was very
very similar to the first one what we
were looking for is a number which one
month it was the y-intercept right so
finally to set well yeah yeah because
you kind of know how to do it from here
so I'm not gonna write out everything so
I'm just gonna say find the y-intercept
which you're going to do in the same way
you did before okay
okay find the way they said and plot it
I should say because we um we found it
it's four and then we put it on there
okay and plot it okay
by the way don't forget it like it's
really bad if you mix up the x and
y-axes that's why it's so important to
label them right because you can
if I swap these around if I made this
one to this one for your graph would be
completely different right it wouldn't
be the same graph so you must get them
matched up correctly so you found the
white assets then you plot it now you
have to find the x-intercept then that's
where we did this right so you say find
the x-intercept by making y0 okay that's
what we did in here okay so you go back
to your original equation okay go back
to the equation and put in everywhere
you see why like overheal you put in
zero instead and that's how we got this
line okay okay once you do that out will
pop it next time you like to okay so
then you plot you draw it on plot the X
sorry that's really missing the
x-intercept okay you plot it and now
you've got your two points you join it
just like before